and uh hey chuckster we have
we have a little something extra for you
not only of
penny kenny the jet smith joining us but
there's a little
shorter tee here uh
at number six and you've got another
chance here
we got a 59-yarder for you you got
kidding off the beach
no i'm not actually i'm i'm actually
practicing in the back and i brought my
i got my uh
glove here when you get betty to putt i
was going to show you a a demonstration
of how to do it
but you're not there yet but first
but first you've got another opportunity
you've got another opportunity from 59
yards out
okay all right and what's the number
what's how much we given to charity on
this one what's up fellas
oh big time shaq is with us too this is
about uh
i believe it's 59 yards chuck
hey what are you gonna call me back man
i've called you five times
i got a hundred thousand on steph curry
it's not a very good bet right now jack
hey
it's really bad hey shaq when you're out
of breath walk into the teeth to your
balls
you know it's a bad stuff
hey hey it's off-season
i'm tired of your colleagues
disrespecting you i had balls made
with shaq's face on it oh yeah knock a
shack ball
in the hole this is ugly okay that's the
ugliest ball in the world right here
hey phil if he hit him if he hits it to
anything like he does in the studio
it's going nowhere this one's going down
right in the hole
i got a dozen shack balls
hey peyton manning i got a question for
you 200 thousand
steph curry 200 000 curry thank you
thanks
guys
what are you wearing kenny you're great
these are these
how do you feel about charles did you
did you bite me
by any french in the imagination see
yourself with the lead
a healthy lead at this point on the
uh early i thought i was going to play
well today i've only heard two bad shots
now uh listen i'm gonna play well today
ernie i promised you that
are you learning a lot since
well phil is playing well you're giving
me some great putting opportunities
it's a team game ernie
how did you take the hit how did you
take the
hitch out you don't have the hitch
anymore well i've been working hard
bring that up no external that doesn't
work anymore
i cannot be psychologically beat down
anymore
so you won't hit you won't hit and you
won't hit
stop i won't hitch
i'm like hey listen i might hit one or
two times but the kids don't do it
many times okay well if you hit this
i want to stay off charles
i see you've been working out during off
season looking real good buddy
you're a funny dude no that's phil that
[Laughter]
ain't
i miss y'all man
please don't hitch don't use that uh box
that's a little bit more kind
of okay he's he's okay on the ground
here okay let's hear phil
now we we've got i want you to stand
over here for a second we're halfway
between the ball of the hole
come on man come on down here
and i want you to notice two things
chuck if you can't read
three words how are you going to read
the greens
don't listen we got to quiet your mind
[Music]
look at this
i'm going to show you the line i got 100
000 on you steph
i'll split
it's going to have to come underneath
this divot it's going to have to attack
he's got that little
mind going like this right now okay
now listen your colleagues are
disrespecting you
quiet your mind get a nice energy
connection with that
with that target and get a good pace
we're slightly uphill
[Music]
hey that's not bad online
don't you have to knock that in i don't
believe charles could knock that in
y'all
let's call it give me kenneth okay i'm
thinking to give me
[Music]
this is peyton manning
nice form peyton manning
that's why i said you can't give that
shot to chuck not a guy
hey congratulations justin you got the
lead
good wi-fi kenny keep it up thank you
guys hey hey
ernie and shaq y'all seen my golf cart
right
yeah i'm surprised
yeah as i recall georgia beat auburn and
we send it back to brian anderson ba
well done ej always the last word
the inside crew by the way walter is
going to donate a hundred thousand
dollars
and of course a half of this fantastic
brother
sixth hole so it carries over to the
next challenge don't forget ej
kenny charles shaq the nba returns
soon december 22nd right here on
tnt and now you know why they give out
a boatload of emmy awards to those four
individuals way to go charles handling
all that
beautiful scenics here stone canyon club
mickelson and barkley still three up as
we go to the seventh